madonna non la lasciamo so fare questa
intro però deve stare calmi micron di
rotta che porta il suo gioco doppiano
infarto all'inizio ma che problemi avete
l attenti ragazzi e vedere dove sono
video sono vari j
siamo tornati su verdi credici anche
perché questo è il primo video che
faccio da quando sono tornato dal
giappone non mi ricordo neanche più come
si fa lo youtube è solo che devo dire
però tutti ragazzi la gente lascia non
mi piace quindi lasciate mi piace grazie
di questa bella schermata sul palco del
protagonista molto gentile con me ne
potevo fare a meno
allora ragazzi non ha una vita e giocare
anche poi dal palco di jason alla fine
come giocare grazie animatore perché si
chiamano animatori personaggi animatore
perché questo in cui gli animatori su
quelli del centro estivo ma come partita
rapida 20 c probabilmente sono riusciti
dei video nel mentre che non ero in
giappone di venerdì 13 però non me lo
ricordo però è da un mese che effettivo
che non ci gioco quindi sono troppo
gasato di riprovarci mai pronto per oggi
che voglio giocare test e niccolò iii
che si sono spaventati prefetto tanti
ragazzi mentre eri giappone è successo
che hanno aggiornato il gioco un sacco
di volte e sono cambiate un botto di
robben detto non so cosa però di preciso
troppo
partiamo subito che siamo vicino alla
macchina quindi un bene magari jason non
mi disse adatta us army il tubero
proprio adesso so manco partito un
attimo che ha sì ecco la pistola
la macchina è qua quindi la macchina ce
l'abbiamo subito abbiamo pure jason come
se non bastasse a cesena è proprio lì
alla macchina ha assunto della sony
losco jason e drogato mi sa che mi ha
visto sono quasi sicuro che mi abbia
visto credo proprio che mi abbia reso
la prima partita non può andare male
ragazzi non può andare male ma siamo
appena partiti non è possibile che
appena torno da giappone sto testa di
culo mi deve fare la faccia no l'ho
baciato intera madonna che male quando
gli ho fatto male veloce e adesso mi sa
che non può incazzato prima non lo era a
sta piazzando le trappole sulla macchina
in panne e maledetto ciao frate ho fatto
culo a jason sono forti gli oat 18 nei
fatti una secco ma se avete devo fare
sempre tutto in questi giorni comunque
ragazzi ha aggiunto un paio di robe che
prima non avevo ad esempio nessuna mappa
sempre aperta perché ho un bonus di
passaggio a un bonus che mi fa avere
subito la mappa perché è una figata
incredibile allora che io trovai a via
via via ma scusami ma dov'è il tizio ma
che cazzo stai facendo
ma prima cosa poi marchiol me non è poi
un brutto modo per morire in camera con
questa tizia era fatto che apre vivai
magari non arriva fino a qua forse se
quella in teoria segue lei grande zia ma
è portato via fantastico bene era una
bella [__] tra l'altro erano aggiornato
il gioco hanno messo delle fig e quindi
aggiornamenti visto gioco sono
fantastici
abbiamo già appurato che gli
aggiornamenti sono una bomba per trovare
chiavi tanica e batteria sull'iter 9
vedere che ce la possiamo fare ma bene
quanto pagato
cosa c'è acqua tanto ragazzi siamo siamo
in quattro hanno l'estate in meta
giocatori a cagare quest'anno la
vinceremo mai è impossibile far ciò
accade che colpo quello la tanica c'è la
tanica grandissimo bravo batteria
batteria allora tecnica ce l'abbiamo la
batteria ragazzi
la batteria da cerco io ancora non ho
visto pagano incredibile un compagno che
fa qualcosa mi sembra assurdo ve lo
giuro
perché non riescono a trovare le chiavi
della non ci posso credere
4 culo 4q locadia sarò a mancheranno
caratteri a ragala batteria batteria c'è
digiuno incredibile manca solo la
batteria il problema è che chi
figurazione però la batteria ed oltre il
focolare dove andare dai proviamo devo
muovermi ragazza comincia come si tratta
vedo se rischio già mettere la tanica ai
la batteria non ci voglio credere mai
distrae e lo distrae e lo distrae di
psych cristo angelelli la batteria ma
loro vista il fucile successo io ok
allora abbiamo tutto posso disarmare la
trappola da adesso hanno messo su
aggiornamento lo so e distrae melo che
io disarmo la trappola qua lo doveva
portare lontano vieni dentro zio mi lì
dentro cavin cyclists vieni dentro
potrebbe sembrare una cosa veramente
brutta da dire a un uomo quando siamo
alle strette vi spariamo in faccia
mentre l'altro mette le cose bravo
c'è un affare questa mente due cose
distraiamo lo distrae non picchia co sta
succedendo la storia del mio zio che va
anche quanti bug mettere la strana e
l'età tanica potrei anche buttarlo giù
col fucile poi mettere la tanica per non
mi basta il tempo via via via via
treviglio via via via buttato bravissimo
20 la tattica perché la tariffazione tra
tanica che presidia sono un po tutto giù
col fucile la tanica vai vai vai e 33
entra dentro l'altra parte non ci voglio
credere
e trio entrate tutti suo partito sono
partito sabbatico fatti da parte non
fate parte barba e basta se siete tutti
ci siete voi siete non vengono meno
niente [__] sica ceo l'occhio che
gesù non potrei trasportati
mi ferma mi chiara che non ci posso
credere dove la mappa lo vedo niente sta
andando
dovete morire tutti la mia musica non ci
posso credere non ci vedo non ci credo
ho vinto ho vinto non hanno vinto non
vinto ancora si transita e trasporta
nella vittoria elettorali e la vittoria
[Musica]
ma che cito e quello così sta roba
c'è un jason nuovo anno nessuno tutto
cazzuto ciao raga è loro
ecco la madonna cos'è sta roba
dovremo premi che il demonio mi chiedo a
metano stante così sto coso sorge la
macchina il perfetto allora devo capire
un attimo così a quella roba libero ma
distrugge sono così e questa è la musica
che c'è quando ottieni si avvicina più
rifiuti di blatche porca vacca
la musica è bruttissima vita sembra di
essere perseguitato all'inferno
vabbè mi chiama che caselle lucifero
combatterò lucifero con una chiave
inglese per del disastro volevo che per
la macchina innanzitutto è già scappata
una volta almeno la seconda dai poteri
non è già qualcosa coltellino svizzero
ritrovare le chiavi prima o poi
maledizione ascentis salve senti ma
seguin per caso
essere il mio compagno non far casino
per cortesia nei piantato un lutto che
ho sentito di la cerca persino e la
macchina invece di fare il finto tonto
inutile di che problemi soffre
esattamente spiegano adori cdc la
trattano bene bene è chiaro che fa la
cosa nella bonita bravo complimenti
armadio guardarli guardali a quello ti
devo prendere a cazzotti sulla mascella
è brutto testa di culo lohan che mancava
telo americani in faccia lo proietta and
disattivare la trappola con faccio c'è
anche 4.000 mese ovunque amica jason in
mezzo vabbè diciamo così per mandare
nell'altra macchina orca vacca non era
me non ero io procedente che orgasmo
quindi va vicino sicuro il fatto è che
sento continuare anche qua piazzato le
trouble ma quali problemi perché ci sono
due kit è uno start up che ha ucciso una
tizia patate sono anche quale chiami per
terra rate trovate pure voi bravi 2
chiara l'amato batte chiamo ci sono
allora era mia perfetta di cala batteria
ragazzo nella materia siamo a posto
prima che non la troveremo mai questa
batteria va bene bravissima bravissima
maria grazia e veloce per organo tutto
chiarire tanica batteria tutto
corri corri con una lepre cornet ma che
cazzo mi geova batteria
se vi dico la tanica brutta stupida va
mettila però non so come si disabilitano
le trappole soccer hanno messo la
modalità di disabilità le tamponata ecco
cosa mi perfetto ok lo fa altrimenti a
batteria sia è veloce batteria tanica
subito ok mi chiami cibo sonora gas solo
ansia perfetto per vedere subito bergamo
quanto tempo e non fa emma re min che no
ma non ci fosse che madonna quanto
brutto che ci su ti mandi agli inferi
aiuto mi sono i palati più su rivelato
va bene non ci credo
tra gli strali lo distrae lo che sennò è
un casino qua gli stranieri dovete
lasciare la macchina con quanto tempo
per azione la macchina che era infatti
chiusa nel lavandino che ogni fiore
passiamo tutta la giornata così si torna
macchina quattro i problemi aiutano con
il cazzo è una mamma che brutto tra
l'altro si ma è solamente di seguire c'è
anche l'altra tizia trovate vabbè ci
posso credere non mi pare così turati
curati e vabbè con demonio
ok ma lei un deficiente dai ma che palle
ma l'altra tizia che sta facendo in
tutto questo
ok curati e veloce perfetto
eccola la pro fare per un'amica ci metto
troppo il problema è che mi piacevo
creduto per un altro no va bene non è
possibile
c'erano mi afferra immediatamente non ci
posso credere a volte visto che l'altro
largo a ricordi come sta facendo l'altra
sta a giocarla monopoly ma ora che non
la vedo più avrei da lei almeno riuscirò
a partire prima o poi basta fatti i
cazzi tuoi
sì sì basta di fare pollice maledizione
mai il problema è che ok ok ok abbia
seminato
l'altra tizia domanda del sospetto che
si calmino le acque ritorno in macchina
perché la macchina che la cosa giusta a
in macchina veloce per due lati highly
notizia o hai fatto qualcosa finalmente
alla seguì lei
segui la piena meno mica gara seguito
non venire per quanti problemi anni
perché di noi dall'altra parte che segue
day avrà la picchia vita qui che merita
di morire a strappi chiavica però c'è
sembra fame ma dai fammi partire basta
che passò due rei facciamo così ma che
palle ma il film the times le catene è
mai bello che riesco a liberarmi ce non
capisco come uno straccio grande
efficiente non posso perdere un posto
deficienza da mi rifiuto momento il
momento al momento distratte di stato
distratto bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye veloce veloce la maledizione
venere intervistatori
intanto ha spaccato la macchina con
successo dai crolli non ce la facciamo
sapere poi parti bardi adesso no no no
no no va bene ma va dai mari già lontano
sono rimasto solo io li ha ammazzati
tutti lato non a button in india non ha
fatto che all'inizio era affanculo cosa
ha fatto l'altra tizia con il pro cosa
ha fatto in tutto questo che cosa ha
fatto o non fatto niente
l'asta faceva best e vabbè quanto
incassato
l'altro è una skin bellissima al tifo
che ci gioca faceva veramente schifo
però i miei compagni facevano ancora più
schifo e poi si lamentano se ho scampo
con la macchina da solo ma solo merito
di deficienti ragazzine che però ci
possiamo concludere qui corrono venerdì
13 è stato fighissimo per soprattutto
per l'ultima partita anche se la prima
novità però è stato veramente figo non
pensavo potesse migliorare così tanto
aggiunto sacconi roma va bene così i
ragazzi sono contento per il rientro dal
giappone in ultimo video va bene così
noi non siamo 100 ragazzi con quello che
mi sa che cosa c'è per il momento mi
piace anche noi come da tradizione sono
a rischio e ci vediamo al prossimo video
ragazzi
[Musica]